cette esquisse de détente survient après
plusieurs mois de tension marqué par des
expulsions de diplomates en cause de
nouvelles sanctions américaines contre
moscou ce vendredi est d'ailleurs
synonyme de date plus doux butoir pour
les départs des diplomates américains
expulsé la correspondance en russie dans
sonic heroes
antoine se dégèle moscou washington
symbolisait un par la rencontre lavrov
blinken de cette semaine peut-il jouer
sur les expulsions de diplomates
oui vous l'avez dit il ya un mois tout
juste le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères imposé à l'ambassade des
états unis à moscou de renvoyer chez eux
10 de ses employés d'ici le 21 mai et le
21 mai c'est aujourd'hui est vrai que
l'entrevue entre sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken a été cordiale et laisse
présager de possibles progrès il a même
été question de je cite déblayer les
décombres notamment concernant le
fonctionnement des missions
diplomatiques
il faut rappeler qu'à l'heure actuelle
il n'y a pas d'ambassadeur américain à
moscou et pas d'ambassadeur russes à
washington
sans parler des expulsions croisées de
diplomates passées et en cours et même
si une rencontre entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine est plus que jamais
dans les tuyaux qui devrait probablement
se tenir dans les toutes prochaines
semaines il reste néanmoins hautement
improbable de voir la diplomatie la
diplomatie russe
rétro pédaler sur ce dossier de
l'expulsion des diplomates américains
pour rappel moscou le faisait alors part
que de pondre de façon symétrique à
l'expulsion de diplomates russes des
états unis d'autant que plusieurs
responsables russes ont déclaré à de
nombreuses reprises
ils tiennent washington pour responsable
de la dégradation des relations entre
les deux pays merci antoine claireaux
pour toutes ces précisions en direct de
moscou